hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so in this video i would
like to make a big overview guys on amc
to see what is happening uh here
especially how this is all related to
the global market and i mean here of
course the speculations about everground
default so let's get into it
[Music]
all right so first we're gonna have a
look guys here at the chart so once
again uh my scenario is here so we made
this first wave in gen 21 then correct
for three months made the second leg
it's been three months we're correcting
and it looks very well like we are about
to make a fifth wave that will go to 130
so the level is still
valid this is still my target but we
need to understand what happened the
past week guys so here basically
so we you can see we completely hear
five waves i was a bit struggling here
to find where are the five waves when
are we correcting and i think that here
what happened is that we had a deeper
and earlier correction than expected and
this is mostly due so this small
correction was for me totally fine
but what happened here guys when we had
this bloody day uh two days ago on
monday is due actually to big money
players just getting back their money
from amc and other mem stocks because
they are fearing a global market
sell-off so fearing this they want to
lighten their investments so they first
gonna go to stocks where they consider
the fundamentals are maybe not as good
as the fundamentals of of the other
stocks they're invested in those kind of
more speculative stocks so amc is of
course one of them given uh the strong
speculation that we had on the stocks in
the past year so i think that if the
ever ground issue is to be solved
then amc will get back right on tracks
and uh go to complete this fifth wave
so the situation right now about
everground if from what i'm seeing in
the news is that the consensus is rather
positive they are about to restructure
the debt
so they're gonna default maybe partially
but the impact it would have on foreign
investors because this is what the
market is fearing that there is a
contagion of this debt
uh from the from china to europe and the
united states so it seems that this
contention should be contained uh
because once again the debt should be uh
restructured and only partially
defaulted so we're gonna keep an eye on
what is happening here guys uh this is
what is gonna give us uh the information
uh technically we're not looking good
guys because we broke the 39.5 level
this was my uh last support of the move
up because you can see it's the last
slow we had here and it was also a level
we had already guys in june right here
here you can see so this is an important
level uh we had as well the 50 moving
average on the daily time frame that was
coming here at 39 39.45
so yes this is not lo this is not good
all right the only positive things uh
i'm seeing here so you guys know that
second wave they like to go to the 61.8
retracement which is here to the 8.2 so
we basically just looking at this are in
typical second wave correction so this
is the only good news i'm seeing here so
once again uh the global market seemed
like it wants to hold so there is still
here a big chance that everything goes
back to normal and that we get back on
tracks so once again i think that here
the information would be given us by
what is happening on everground so
that's it for me i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to click on the like sub and bell
button so you're gonna be the first to
know when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore i'll see you guys